matthew mcgill is a long way from home
this canada day i felt that i needed to
do
whatever i could do
to help with the fight mcgill is 49 a
father of two and a brand new
grandfather but instead of relaxing with
his family this holiday he's quite
literally in the trenches trying to stop
russians from advancing here in ukraine
i have skills that i thought would be
useful here signal skills honed as a
canadian forces member in the 90s canada
has trained over 30 000 ukrainian forces
and part of their ability to work in the
field is a tribute to canadian training
in four months here mcgill says his
perspective is forever changed driven by
scenes like these how horrible the
russians are in their treatment of the
ukrainian civilians
has made me feel more strongly about the
need for me to be here monday's attack
on the shopping center is russia's most
blatant killing of civilians so far 18
dead dozens more injured days later
they're still cleaning up still finding
body parts
then on thursday night russia sent two
more cruise missiles into an apartment
building near the port city of odessa
officials say 20 or more were killed
russia has stepped up its missile
strikes in central and eastern areas of
ukraine in the last two weeks mcgill
told us he's seen fellow soldiers die on
the front line being hit by missiles and
artillery
very close is something that will change
everybody but he remains here by choice
it's very canadian to work for the piece
of the world
it's very canadian to sacrifice your
life in order to defend a foreign
country against aggression it's very
canadian to
not think of your own welfare but to
think of the broader welfare mcgill
spent a month training with ukrainians
before taking up his post he says they
still need more arms support on the
ground
and when i asked him if he had a message
in mind on a day many of us are
reflecting on canadian values he shared
this just be grateful
that we don't have war in canada because
it's
it's crap here
it's it's no fun
and everybody suffers so just be very
thankful that in canada we we have peace
and
we're not under threat it's a
perspective forged by extraordinary
courage and determination that hits
close to home even from a world away
sean o'shea global news cremenschuk
ukraine